bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 sport allez on passe
tout de suite au sommaire de cette
édition des 6 et 7 décembre prochain la
ville de viroflay va accueillir une
compétition inédite sur le territoire la
première coupe de france de quidditch
inspiré de la saga harry potter la
discipline est en pleine effervescence
en france le principe de la boxe
française ahmed el moussaoui va tenter
dans quelques jours de décrocher la
ceinture européenne des welters
l'occasion de montrer au monde de la
boxe qu'il a franchi un nouveau palier
avec mille quatre licenciés l'étoile
sportive de trappes est désormais le
premier club des yvelines en termes
d'effectifs explication de la réussite
d'un club désormais reconnue pour sa
formation et vous le savez vous avez
l'habitude en fin d'émission l'essentiel
des résultats du week-end mais place
tout d'abord au quidditch je le disais
dans les titres le ce week-end des 6 et
7 décembre la ville de viroflay va
accueillir sa première compétition de
quidditch et c'est la première coupe de
france de la discipline inspirée de la
saga harry potter que vous connaissez
certainement la discipline est en pleine
croissance en france la fédération est
tout jeune et pour parler de cet
événement et vous faire découvrir cette
pratique sportive le président de la
fédération française de quidditch est
présent sur le plateau du 7-8 sport
aurel cosseron bonsoir à vous merci
d'être là vous êtes accompagné de adrien
di fabio l'organisateur de la coupe de
france bon soir rien alors première
question parce que évidemment on a envie
de savoir
le quidditch en réel ça que ça marche
comment alors le quit chambre s est très
proche du vrai sport de harry potter tel
que décrit par 10 k rowling
donc ça va se jouer avec différentes
balle la principale c'est le soif qui
est une balle de volée légèrement
dégonflé qui va être dans la main voilà
c'est celle ci nous voilà cette belle va
servir à marquer des buts en passant à
travers les trois anneaux disposés de
chaque côté du terrain
à chaque fois qu'elle traverse et à noël
elle donne dix points à l'équipe que
marquer l'autre balles importantes du
jeu c'est le cognard ses sept balles si
elle va être utilisée par deux joueurs
dans chaque équipe
sachant qu'à 3 cognard en jeu et elle va
permettre de mettre hors jeu des joueurs
pendant un certain temps à chaque fois
qu'un joueur va être touché par un
cognard il va devoir descendre de son
ballet retourner jusqu'à ses anneaux les
toucher et seulement à ce moment là il
pourra recommencer à jouer et la
dernière balle du jeu la plus importante
pour certains c'est le disque d'or voilà
c'est le fameux vivre dehors c'est ça
donc adapté comme on a pu pour le monde
des non sorciers
donc cette balle va être accrochée
derrière le short d'un joueur neutre et
il y aura un joueur dans chaque équipe
qui devra essayer de récupérer cette
balle sans toucher le joueur quand il
récupère cette balle il rapporte 30
points son équipe et en plus il met fin
au match
vous avez dit pendant votre explication
des cendres du ballet ça veut dire que
vous avez quand même aussi le ballet
comme dans comme dans le film exactement
on joue sur des balais qui ne sont pas
des balais volants comme on peut trouver
dans les moteurs mais qui sont quand
même des balles est un peu plus court
que leur ballet que vous pouvez utiliser
chez vous pour le ménage il faut entre
80 cm et 1 mètre 20 et donc ça peut être
du pdc du bois n'importe quoi en fait et
ça permet donc de créer un malus dans le
jeu comme pouvoir sous les images si on
tombe de son ballet on est mis hors jeu
pendant un certain temps
le ballet ne doit pas toucher le sol on
doit dans la mesure du possible toujours
tenir son balai ça permet de dire qu'un
joueur est en jeu en fait commencé née
cette pratique qu'on va dire réel adrien
du queen's j'ai cru comprendre c'était
aux états unis un petit peu deux
étudiants un peu fan de la saga qui
s'ils ont mis un petit peu c'est ça
exactement en fait l'auteur rawlings
avait dit avait répondu à des interviews
en disant que non ce n'était pas
possible et qu'elle ne voyait pas
comment ça pouvait être adaptée et au
final des passionnés on a fini par
adapter les règles et à se rendre compte
que oui c'était possible et que oui ça
pouvait finir par devenir compétitif et
au final aux états unis il ya des
équipes dans toutes les dans toutes les
universités
il ya un niveau extrêmement élevé en
france il ya à peu près dix clubs
recensés
donc la pratique commence à agrandir le
public qui vient justement pratiquer le
le quidditch c'est des fans d'harry
potter à la base ou maintenant ça
commence à s'élargir un petit peu pas
seulement parce mans il ya dix clubs
officiels adhérents de la fédération il
ya 26 clubs en tout en france donc près
du double et on trouve deux un peu tout
ça à commencer évidemment par les fans
purs et durs de harry potter qui voulait
jouer aux sports de leur sorcier favori
maintenant il ya des équipes dans
lesquelles la majorité des joueurs n'ont
jamais lu ou vieux les harry potter
il ya des gens qui font ça vraiment
juste pour la pratique du sport il ya
encore des clopes il continue à le faire
juste pour le plaisir de harry potter on
trouve vraiment de tout parmi les
joueurs et vous justement comment vous y
êtes mis au quidditch réel réduire par
hasard en fait c'est mon frère qui m'en
avait parlé en disant oui samedi
prochain je vais jouer au quidditch et
je pensais que c'était un truc comme ça
qu'on était une fois en initiation puis
de la semaine d'après il m'a dit moment
la semaine prochaine retour le quidditch
et là j'ai compris c'était un vrai club
de sport qui fonctionnait vraiment j'ai
fini par la compagnie et à mon premier
entraînement
j'étais tellement essoufflé tellement
fatigué avant même le début du premier
match que je me suis dit il faut que je
parte maintenant vous alors je vais
mourir
j'entends dire que c'est difficile
physiquement c'est vraiment un sport à
proscrire physique voilà je suis resté
comme des plus deviner
maintenant j'adore mais oui c'est plus
qu'une pratique adaptée d'un livre c'est
vraiment la volonté de créer un nouveau
sport et c'est très très physique ça
peut être aussi physique que peuvent
l'être le rugby ou le handball c'est
l'espace pour qu'alexandre notre
consultant connaît bien le handball est
justement par rapport à cette pratique
c'est accessible à tous quand même
rassuré nous parce que oui bien sûr pour
l'instant le quidditch on a vraiment
tous les types de profils ce week-end à
la coupe de france on va pouvoir voir
des joueurs extrêmement bon qui pourtant
physiquement sont pas comme n'importe
qui en fait
pas spécialement affûté pas spécialement
pas spécialement musclé où que ce soit
et resteront alors comment justement
devient un bon joueur de quidditch
une fois qu'on a bien compris les
mécanismes du jeu
ben il faut courir de plus en plus vite
il ya des contacts entre les joueurs
parce que sur les images on a pu voir
notamment c'est vrai que parfois ya des
contacts pour attraper ce fameux vivent
dehors c'est ça c'est extrêmement
physique donc il ya différents types de
contacts autorisés y en a cinq ans tout
mais c'est en à drouot plaquage par
exemple on a devra rentrer dans un
adversaire c'est interdit par exemple de
saisir un adversaire à demain pour le
faire tomber au sol quand il ya des
limites
il faut rappeler vous voyez de
différents types de joueurs tout à
l'heure que c'est un sport mixte
donc on va forcément avoir des hommes et
des femmes dans l'équipe en face de soi
donc le sport et le règlement ont dû
s'adapter à cette condition on n'envoie
pas un mec de 1 mètre 90 et 200 kg sur
une fille doit mettre 50 et 70 kg donc
un juste milieu en général par les
listes verts ça on n'en voit pas une
fille d'un mètre 90 sur et pour revenir
à la coupe de france est notre actualité
locale comment ça va se dérouler sur
deux jours vous allez ici justement
essayer de profiter de l'événement pour
faire des initiations faire découvrir la
dissiper alors oui exactement en fait on
aura des matchs sur les quatre demi
journées du week-end et pendant que les
équipes seront en pause du midi
eh ben on aura des initiations pour les
gens qui seront là il y aura deux
initiations et cette première manche de
coupe de france c'est pour derrière
faire pérenniser un petit peu la
compétition faire plus de manches
peut-être ailleurs en région
112 une coupe de france l'année
prochaine
ils sont sans doute une coupe de france
et ensuite
peut-être d'autres compétitions à venir
par la suite en fonction du résultat
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
passé sur le plateau du 7-8 sport pour
parler de quidditch et donc si vous
voulez aller voir ces sportifs rendez
vous ce week end à viroflay tout le tout
le week-end 1-2 samedi et dimanche entre
9h et 18h merci beaucoup à tous les deux
on enchaîne avec la boxe et je le disais
dans les titres de cette édition
le prince de la boxe française ahmed el
moussaoui va tenter dans quelques jours
de décrocher la ceinture européenne dans
la catégorie welters l'occasion de
montrer au monde de la boxe qu'il peut
et surtout qu'il a franchi un nouveau
palier en terme de progression pour
devenir l'un des meilleurs du vieux
continent en tout cas le verrier roi
s'en donne les moyens reportages
réalisés avec patrick jacques de dixmude
et william l ses yeux transpire
l'ambition et la rage de vaincre
un an après son titre de champion de
france ahmed el moussaoui s'attaque à la
ceinture de l'union européenne des
welters en l'espace de douze mois le
prince de la boxe française énormément
mûri et s'est professionnalisé suivi par
un ostéopathe et un diététicien le vert
virois s'est entouré d'un préparateur
physique jean baptiste congourdeau pour
ne plus penser qu'à la boxe
j'essaie de mettre la chambre de mon
compte et d'un cap encore à franchir
maintenant je suis classé je passais 9e
marocain je pense que après ce combat là
pour moins cher
actuellement je fais partie des
meilleurs européens après maintenant
voilà c'est à moi de prouver que je suis
vraiment pour le ring il a également
changé d'entraîneur le chapitre
américain est refermé c'est désormais
youssef ben ari qui s'occupe de lui
entre les cordes avec lui ahmed el
moussaoui travail plus l'aspect tactique
d'un combat mon ancien entraîneur aux
etats-unis c'était plus du long et c'est
plus la résistance
par contre là c'est plus court on va
dire une heure et demie deux heures
d'entraînement mais super intensifs et
les entraînements sont beaucoup plus
variés et je sens progression de 8
tel un scientifique youssef barritt
décrypte le moindre des mouvements de
son boxeur l'objectif excellé dans la
simplicité pour s'éviter toute mauvaise
surprise le jour du combat
c'est un boxeur l'on chérit grand pour
sa catégorie donc avec une grande
amplitude de bras c'est quelqu'un de
mobiles de combattif donc rapide mais
qui prend trop de risques
voilà alors c'est bien pour le public
c'est bien pour ses fans et c'est moins
bien pour la suite de sa carrière
il faut préserver ses qualités un petit
peu de combattants le desservent un
petit peu ce jour là à l'entraînement
son partenaire n'est autre que le
challenger pour la ceinture européenne
des super welters
karim est rouge et au bout de quelques
reprises ahmed enlève son casque de
protection comme pour ressentir un peu
plus l'intensité du combat que pourrait
lui réserver son adversaire car il lui
faudra faire face au champion d'espagne
aitor nieto un boxeur longiligne de 30
ans au même profil physique que le
français 6 avec seulement une défaite en
22 combats le vert lierois part favori
il devra confirmer les espoirs placés en
lui depuis son titre national
réponse le 6 décembre prochain
le soir sur le 7-8 sports alexandre
taillefer notre consultant handball fait
un petit arrêt sur images ce sans langue
de bois comme d'habitude sur la saison
le début de saison de plaisir montigny
le bretonneux et le chesnay des équipes
qui enchaîne les victoires depuis
quelques semaines pour soir alexandre
remercie d'être là une petite question
en aparté avant quand même parce que
vous deviez pas connaître le coït
j'imagine avant de venir ce soir vous
pourriez peut-être vous servir des
techniques physiques autres pour
entraîner vos joueurs non je ne suis pas
j'ai pas de ballon donc à proprement dit
contient vraiment dans la main pour
marquer un but donc je suis pas sûr
après en commun oui à la course il a
légèrement ce que j'ai fait comprendre
des autorisations de contact comme
l'irlande
mais bon hormis chat n'y a pas beaucoup
de points communs
on va revenir au handball dont je le
disais vous allez nous parler de
duchesnay de montigny et de plaisir on
commence avec au chesnay équipe
nationale 3 ils sont deuxièmes à ce
stade de la saison c'est une bonne
surprise pour vous ah oui parce que si
on considère à l'année dernière où ils
sont maintenus à la dernière ou avant
dernière journée les retrouver là à ce
niveau là c'est bon pour pour les
yvelines c'est bon pour le club parce
qu'ils ont évolué jusqu'en d2 il ya de
cela quelques années mais il était en
deuil a encore pas si longtemps il ya
deux ans donc bon j'espère pour eux
qu'ils vont retrouver rapidement la
nationale 2 pour cela il faudrait finir
premier pour se qualifier
automatiquement les deuxièmes on est
barragiste
alors pour l'instant ils sont deuxièmes
mais faut savoir que jusqu'au 7e ils
sont à une victoire donc à cette série
est très resserré
donc ils sont à égalité premier et un
deuxième égalité que le premier mais
après c'est ça se joue dans les sept
premiers sont en une victoire donc il
leur reste deux matchs contre ses 7
premiers d'ici la fin des phases aller
et pour l'instant ils ont fait deux
victoires et deux défaites avec les
équipes concurrentiel donc voilà ils ont
un s'ils veulent espérer monter il faut
à tout prix qui bat les trois matches
qui arrivent un peu plus facile ce
week-end et puis deux autres difficile
contre l'année à domicile est compté à
serris et la série c'est très très dur
de les gagner et ce week end ailleurs
ils se sont imposés face à beauvais 33 à
28 qu'est-ce qui peut métamorphoser un
petit peu un groupe comme ça là vous le
disiez ils ont frôlé la relégation la
saison passée puis là il se bat pour la
montée marianne eu un changement
d'entraîneur après pas si c'est l'unique
lui nous faisons mais actuellement il ya
eu un changement d'entraîneur
ensuite il y avait une intégration
quelques jeunes l'année dernière
donc maintenant c'est leur deuxième
saison certains sont arrivés en plus de
jeunes je parle donc après peut-être pas
envie de revivre la même saison et la
conscience morale arbres peut-être
peut-être sa part me de revivre la même
saison galère de l'année dernière s
concerné tout de suite dès le début de
saison voilà après les poules ne se
ressemblent pas toujours d une année à
l'autre tout seul alors combien des
effectifs mans on va enchaîner avec
plaisir on reste chez les hommes plaisir
que club que vous connaissez bien
évidemment là on est en en prénationale
c'est une division que connaît bien le
club pour l'équipe première parce que ça
fait longtemps que l'équipe première
évolue à ce niveau comment vous jugez
justement ce début de saison on va dire
presque parfait ils sont invaincus
oui bah pour l'instant c'est ils sont
dans les clous comme on dit ils ont fait
une très bonne perf
la semaine dernière il ya deux semaines
perdant contre saint gratien
à domicile ils ont battu 31 28 et c'est
un bon score parce que c'est une équipe
qui qui est qui vise la montée saint
gratien avait beaucoup de jeunes
notamment deux jeunes qui ont été en
équipe de france j'aime qui sont des -18
ans et sont des petits qui court
beaucoup et plaisir à les battre sur ce
terrain là ce n'était pas forcément
évident voilà maintenant ils vont
enchaîner les gros matches là ils vont
rencontrer ma maison ils vont rencontrer
à l' us métro paris sportifs tous les
toutes les équipes qui sont en haut du
classement
voilà donc notamment à mon avis l us
métro sera l'équipe
qu'ils sont en tête qui sera la plus
dure à battre c'est d'ailleurs la
meilleure attaque depuis le début de
saison pour l'instant plaisir ça c'est
signe aussi d'une puissance et d'une
confiance du groupe sur les phases
offensives
sinon d'un projet de jeu sur le jeu
rapide et qui apporte beaucoup de buts
très rapidement
donc s'ils sont en accord avec leur
projet de jeu c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
qui sont meilleures attaques ça veut
dire que peut-être cette année on va
peut-être avoir cette fameuse montée du
côté de plaisir ça serait quand même une
bonne récompense j'espère bien ce serait
une bonne course pour les joueurs qui
sont investis depuis certains quasiment
une dizaine d'années des jeunes joueurs
du championnat de france de l'année
dernière ont intégré le groupe donc donc
voila moi je pense qu'il ya il ya le
groupe pour pouvoir monter cette année
maintenant il faut qu'il prenne match
après match et qui ne perd pas de points
en route comme ça a pu être le cas
l'année dernière
on termine avec les dames et monty n'est
donc en nationale 2 évidemment après un
début laborieux deux premières journées
difficiles avec des défaites et balla
pour l'instant elles sont sur une
superbe série les joueuses de philippe
l'étrange cette fois ci c'est l'année
peut-être de la possible montée ou pas
alors eux aussi c'est un souhait qu'ils
ont depuis un certain nombre d'années de
monter de remonter en n1 j'étais à
quelques années pour les mêmes raisons
c'est assez compliqué un premier monte
deuxième barrage ifa c'est très
compliqué donc du coup pour l'instant
ils sont bien remontés à savoir que les
deux premières défaites en avait une qui
était complet première c'était un petit
peu plus d'envié voilà je pense que ça
va être très très dur d'aller chercher
parce qu'ils me paraissent quand même
assez assez au dessus de tout le monde
épuisé mais en vol a réservé une équipe
voilà dans l'élite
voilà est par contre aller chercher
cette deuxième place et tenter de monter
avec le bar h et c'est envisageable
voilà maintenant ils vont avoir un match
difficile contre vie demande bientôt là
d'ici deux trois journées
et puis après faut voir tout prix
gagnent ce match là pour pouvoir
conforter leur deuxième place et espérer
pouvoir monter au vu de phase retour
très bien merci alexandre d'autres votre
analyse toujours aussi pointue avant de
refermer notre page handball un dernier
résultat la team 78 que vous connaissez
bien poursuit sa route dans le
championnat de france moins de 18 ans
pour le compte de la 8e journée vos
joueurs alexandre taillefer se sont
imposés 37 à 30
astellas face à stella sport ils restent
co leaders avec paris
galaxy on enchaîne avec le football je
vous disais dans les titres avec mille
quatre licenciés l'étoile sportive de
trappes est désormais le premier club
des yvelines en termes d'effectifs
explication de la réussite d'un club
désormais reconnue pour sa formation
montage de sandrine fontaine avec tous
ses licenciés trappe pourrait composer
90 équipes mais au-delà de l'aspect
purement quantitatif ce chiffre de mille
licenciés est un symbole de qualité de
la formation trappistes en l'espace de
dix ans le club a formé de nombreux
éducateurs diplômés pour en compter
désormais une cinquantaine à nous le
nombre salle n'est pas du tout important
si on a augmenté comme ça je pense que
c'est vraiment le travail qu'a eue
depuis des années qui a été mis en place
et surtout la qualité la qualité qui
pèsent vraiment de partout chez les
joueurs chez les dirigeants chine et par
an depuis 2004 l'étoile sportive de
trappes a gagné 50 % d'adhérents
désormais la formation du club est
reconnu au delà des frontières de la
ville
que cela soit sur les pelouses de
guimier ou chant sac ici le football est
réservé à tous à l'image de la nouvelle
équipe féminine qui a pris forme en
début de saison j'étais joueur mais
j'estime que à l'école de foot c'est le
passage le plus important pour un enfant
c'est là où est ce qu'on apprend les
bases donc céder les bases on les a pas
c'est difficile ensuite de monter sur
les catégories différentes
avec trois équipes de jeunes évoluant en
ligue régionale depuis 2006 l'étoile
sportive de trappes a permis à huit
jeunes footballeurs d'intégrer des
centres de formation à l'image
nissim rafa parti pour laval quand
l'enfant est bon il est bon c'est à dire
que si ce garçon c'est un anelka si ce
garçon est un zidane ce garçon est un
messie alors c'est un joueur d'exception
on fera en sorte qu'ils deviennent celui
qui doit être pour le coup ci c'est un
gamin qui a beaucoup moins de
possibilités qui est allé on va dire un
niveau moindre
on le fera aller au bout de ce qu'il est
capable de produire sur cette saison
2014-2015 trap est désormais le premier
club des yvelines devant ou ou encore
versailles en terme de licenciés et on
commence ce jt résultats par du tennis
de table et de la pro a féminine pour le
compte de la 7e journée les joueuses de
france sont liés on parle évidemment
d'elancourt recevait quevilly lancer
parfaitement par yanan wang
eva odorova s'arrache pour offrir un
deuxième point à elancourt et si audrey
zarif s'incline face à galina dvorak le
ctt eux s'imposent finalement 4 points à
1 et se hisse à la 4e place de poids à
six points du leader messin football 10e
journée de division d'honneur et
versailles a cartonné le blanc mesnil à
domicile victoire 5 buts à 1 les
versailles et conservent leur troisième
place au classement en promotion
d'honneur la mauvaise série se poursuit
pour l'étoile sportive de trappes les
saint quentinois se sont inclinés sur la
pelouse de villemomble ce week-end 1 but
à 0 et avec ce septième match sans
victoire consécutifs les trappistes
continuent leur dégringolade au
classement de cette poule d de ph et
pointent désormais à l'avant dernier
rang au 11e rang exactement foot féminin
après en division d'honneur montigné
toujours dans la course pour la montée
recevait la lanterne rouge paris ca ce
samedi au stade de la couldre match
comptant pour la 7e journée de
championnat et c'était un jour sans pour
les joueuses de jean dany grosset
lésigny monteyne se sont fait étriller 5
but à zéro c'est la première fois de la
saison que montigny ne trouve pas le
chemin des filets au cours d'une
rencontre malgré cette défaite le club
saint quentinois conserve sa deuxième
place au classement à quatre longueurs
du leader saint denis je pense que ce
championnat est très serré
je pense qu'on fera le point au mois de
janvier il reste encore des matches
c'est vrai qu'on va beaucoup compter sur
le pari c'est à pouvoir freiner à nos
concurrents directs
il faut être réaliste là dessus rien
n'est perdu comme je ne dirai rien n'est
perdu il faut y croire jusqu'à la fin il
faut continuer à travailler
je pense que c'est une bonne claque
aujourd'hui pour la suite du championnat
et lésigny monteyne pourront prendre
leur revanche dans quelques jours
puisque le 14 décembre prochain ils
affronteront le pari ces ajustements
pour le compte du 1er tour fédéral de la
coupe de france féminine de son côté
voisins bretons ne recevra bourges ont
continué foot féminin pour le compte de
la cinquième journée de promotion
d'honneur et l'on court 9e recevait le
troisième taverny ce samedi à
guy-boniface diminué par les blessures
les amazones ont encore montré un
toutefois une belle qualité de jeu mais
trop d'imprécision dans le dernier geste
menés au score les élans courtoise
égalise en seconde période sur coups de
pied arrêtés mais elles se font une
nouvelle fois surprendre score final 2
buts à 1 et une cinquième défaite en
autant de journées de championnat les
joueuses de d'analysé de données d
l'aigle pardon reste 9e avec 6 points
le match de voisins-le-bretonneux face à
l'académie 77 a été reporté ce la
continuité depuis deux ans on a un peu
de mal à s'y colle au gicm on en a perdu
déjouer ce qu'ils nous ont fait du mal
un leurre des pins et puis là c'est la
continuité pourtant dans le football on
je pense qu'on est une des équipes dans
ce championnat qu'on essaie du moins de
pratiquer le meilleur football ce psycho
logiquement vu qu'on a un monde de
victoires et ballet fillon
en plus de vols coin en rugby ce
week-end plaisir a loupé l'occasion il
faut le dire de confirmer son renouveau
pour le compte de la 9ème journée de
fédérale 2 dernières joutes des matches
aller le prc 9e recevait le septième
domois robert barran si les joueurs de
frédéric jardin réalisent une entame de
match quasi parfaite en inscrivant deux
essais grâce notamment aux avant que
vous venez de voir les plaisirs oib
seront lagarde en seconde période pour
finalement s'incliner 25 à 15 et sans
bonus défensif
après deux victoires consécutives le prc
rechute et restent englués à cette
neuvième place de fédérale 2 en
promotion d'honneur
le sky rugby a décroché de son côté un
succès important face aux quatrièmes
clairement les joueurs de guillaume
payen s'impose à domicile 21 à 12 et
dans le même temps le deuxième moment si
vous le voyez s'est également imposée du
coup au classement pas de chamboulement
le sky rugby reste dans le trio de tête
de cette poule de ph avec 29 points 10
longueurs du leader us au massif central
place au basket et les féminines de
l'entente le chesnay-versailles se sont
enfin réveillés face aux derniers calais
le lcv s'est largement imposé 82 à 39
lors de la 10e journée de nationale 2
chez les hommes le chiffre du week-end
c'est zéro c'est toujours le nombre de
victoires de l'entente le chesnay
versailles lors de la 10e journée de n3
le fcv recevait le deuxième fois ci dans
le derby yvelinois malgré un match
courageux une première période accrochée
40 à 34 pour poissy les joueurs de
romain dubosson logiquement céder peu à
peu du terrain pour finalement
s'incliner 87 à 65 le fcv reste 11e de
sa poule poissy caracol de son côté
toujours en tête avec gennevilliers de
ce côté trap a cartonné boigny vous
allez le voir 102 à 77 au gymnase paul
mallet ce samedi soir et conserve sa 7e
place au classement
on passe au raid de l'arbre vert et des
nouvelles d'anne-sophie chaste 7
yvelinoise qui participent à l'édition
2014 de ce raid amazones au cambodge qui
s'est terminé la semaine passée après
six journées d'épreuves de traque de vtt
ou encore de canoë à travers le le
cambodge son équipe les impacts za
conclu cette édition 2014 au 24e
rang au classement général l'objectif du
top 30 annoncée est donc réalisée
évidemment anne-sophie nous racontera
son expérience dans un prochain 7,8
sport et enfin une dernière info avant
de nous quitter c'est de la gym et vous
le savez peut-être les 15 et 16 novembre
dernier avait lieu le championnat
régional ile de france ouest de
gymnastique rythmique et avec 18 gym
n'assure 19 présenter sélectionné pour
la zone l'étape supplémentaire le club
d'elancourt maurepas était une fois
encore bien représenté la suite de l'
aventure aura lieu les 13 et 14 décembre
prochains pour la zone donc cette
dernière étape avant les championnats de
france
c'est la fin de ce set 8 faut remercier
encore une fois de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain même lieu même
heure d'ici là excellente soirée sur tv
fille